hello and welcome to the sheiki science
show where in this video i had great fun
speaking with professor gordon lithgow
and one of his phd students edward
anderton
discussing all about the worms c elegans
and small molecules that prolong
lifespan through enhancing molecular
stability i hope you enjoy our
conversation
so hi gordon hi edward thank you bray
for joining me today and welcome to the
bishop science show
thank you for the invitation it's great
to be here yeah it's great
so i thought i'd uh start with like one
of the kind of generic questions that
question that's always interesting to
hear different people's perspectives
which is
what is aging to you and how do you
think we should be prescribing aging as
i know you've been using the concepts um
and talking about the aging floor in
general but jury science as well as the
concept
yeah i mean it's a huge question
actually
and
i think we're still not very good at
actually defining aging to be honest we
know how to manipulate it and we can
talk about all these pathways and
just tissue changes and molecular
changes and we can do all of that
there's textbooks of that but the the
question what is aging is still i think
elusive in a way
to me it still is this
deterioration with time
it's an increase in mortality specific
mortality rates
which is a very terrible definition but
at least it's something you can say
that's true that happens in almost all
animals
um
but the the the gerosized thing and what
you do pile in here uh
i mean the genocides thing is really the
idea that whatever aging is
uh if we some at some time have a cam
you know it's a chemical biology
explanation of aging whatever it is we
do think it causes disease
chronic disease in late life and it's
everything all the cancers
alzheimer's parkinson's osteoarthritis
osteoporosis the big list of diseases
and the key there is the word cause
because that's not generally i think
still accepted by the wider biomedical
community the idea that aging is a cause
of something i don't know i mean
did when you started thinking about
aging was did you think about it as a
cause
of disease yeah yeah i mean it seemed it
seemed kind of obvious
from the research
um
because we can manipulate the aging
process right so we have interventions
that can
slow down the aging process or at least
it seems that way and usually there's a
concomitant decrease in the prevalence
of disease or diseases pushed away
which would
suggest that there's a causal aspect to
it
um
i don't know i don't really have
anything to add in terms of definition
of aging
yeah but i mean it's worth noting that
that
you are of
maybe the first generation
of
young younger scientists who kind of
accept that idea of application as a
cause of disease um if you go to all the
major
neuroscience institutes and cancer
institutes across the world
you'll find very little expertise on
aging itself
and that's kind of stunning if if aging
is really the cause of these things how
is it that we we're here as a biomedical
community are still not
you know employing that in our ways to
find new drugs and new interventions
yeah so i mean how are you using the
like jury science center kind of
communicates what this field really is
hopefully you know the the word was we
came up with a word here actually the
buck institute and it was it was it was
15 years ago and it was to to represent
the fact that we had expertise in
disease and then people working on worms
and flies and yeast and suddenly
realizing we're all working on the same
thing
and we thought what what is this it's
not biology it's not geriatric medicine
and so we came up with a umbrella term
geroscience to try and describe the
interface between the
normal aging processes that we're
studying and the disease processes
i see and you brought up ones um which
is how i kind of made them but that's
kind of like i guess your model organism
of choice so i guess can you
talk more about why and
what's so fascinating about
these creatures as another organism
yeah i mean they're a fantastic model to
study aging
precisely because they have a very short
lifespan
um so they only live approximately two
to three weeks in the lab
um
we understand the genetics
quite well um we understand the
development quite well they have a set
number of cells and we understand how
those cells develop
and what's interesting is that in many
ways the c elegans is a good model for
more complex aging in
mammals and in humans because they
display many of the same aging
phenotypes
so they they slow down with age they get
a sort of sarcopenia where the muscles
degrade um their intestinal
lumen degrades and so they get kind of
leaky gut which is seen in mammals too
um and so in many ways you can study
these diseases of aging in the worm a
very short period of time
i mean it's truly remarkable just to
repeat what you've said in some way that
that so the the first mutations that
were shown to extend lifespan and the
metazoan were found in c elegans back in
tom johnson's lab in 1988
university colorado and
i and you know i got interested in that
at the time but i never imagined would
be having conversations about human
health right these same genes
and then more recently we've seen
you know sort of chemical compound like
or drug-like interventions
and of the published and unpublished
stuff that i know about it's looking
like you can go from the worm to a mouse
at some sort of hillary like 50
which is unbelievable really i mean to
think about so we're really hitting
conserved biology so you go back and say
well actually the worm has proven to be
amazing that we can actually go into a
mouse in some pre-clinical
setting uh with uh be aging pathologies
or lifespan itself and see effects from
these these compounds that were
identified in worms i i'm stunned by
that yeah i mean i think there's a paper
uh that you published a couple of years
ago where you've identified about six
different compounds that seem to be able
to extend the lifespan and that's in
like the c elegans like equivalent of
the mouse itp interventions testing
program oh yes
yes um one based program and so could
you elaborate more on this and talk
about essentially these different
compounds that seem like most promising
sure i mean the program itself was um
it came about because
some of us felt there was a problem with
the scientific literature
so
we published a paper flashy paper and
science you know antioxidants extend
lifestyle
and then two other labs excellent labs
could not repeat that data and it was
really shocking at the time um and and
we kind of moved away from even using
chemical confidence in the worm at all
for a while
and it was only a decade later that
people started to say well this is
actually happening too often it's
happened more than more than once
um we we could always replicate our own
data but we simply couldn't tell other
people how to do it you know
so so um the end national institute of
aging set up first of all a mouse
intervention testing program and a worm
intervention testing program
and the the
the idea was to say
sort this out work out what's going on
you know find protocols that work
between labs
and essentially both organizations have
done that so we published our first
paper uh testing a bunch of compounds
that were kind of
probably well known to some people
they've been in the literature already
in different ways
but we've established a protocol where
all three labs this is patrick
phillips's lab and monica driscoll's lab
across the us
all three labs could replicate the data
and they did not see
variation between
the laboratories themselves
and so some of the compounds that came
out thioflavin t was an example of an
amyloid binding compound that worked in
and it didn't just work in the labs this
is a critical point actually it wasn't
just the lab strains we also tested wild
straights recently brought in from the
wild
and and different species of see
serophobitis and cerebritis is
incredibly genetically diverse and so
what you're really doing is you're
testing the idea that
if a compound works in in this genetic
background could it also work in a
different one and that's relevant to to
us right that's relevant
and um so yeah
it was kind of interesting so we did
find a couple of compounds that really
worked well uh we found a whole lot of
others including
at least one that we published
previously did not work at all
and uh
and and then but you know
maybe one of the biggest things that
came out of this was
the variability in experiments and the
realization that we don't document
enough about how we're doing experiments
in order for people to replicate
and and actually just the natural
variation in lifespan experiments from
run to run was
enormous it was amazing we had no idea
that existed until we did this kind of
thing at scale
yeah and it's um it's interesting you
brought up by clavin t which i know yes
you say binds like amyloid fibroids
which are kind of like aggregated
proteins and so does that these
compounds that you've um have arisen
from these tests has that therefore
given us some indication of the
underpinning molecular processes
yeah i'll hand it over to you to talk
about proteostasis but um
you probably realize that every aging
scientist you talk to thinks that
they're working on the most important
mechanisms
so yeah so we think this is the most
important
but just describe where we are with this
um
yeah so you your question is
um how have we learned from the
compounds or how have we learned about
the role of proteomics this agent um i
guess
yeah so maybe your best place to talk
about um fire team what we learned from
those studies because i was sure prior
to my time in the lab yeah um but in
terms of protein obviously i mean my
thesis project um revolves around a
project that started in the lab a decade
ago now really which is looking at how
we know that with aging this isn't just
in worms in mammals too there's an
increase in these detergent insoluble
protein aggregates so that's just
protein aggregates which
stuck together and become these very
resistant
protein advocates and uh
and so what they found is that with
aging this happens in the worm
and we can extract these protein
aggregates and we can look at them by
mass spectrometry so we can see what
kinds of proteins aggregate with aging
we find that it's very reproducible it's
the same kinds of candidate proteins
that come all the time
so what we found is that there are
certain compounds to kind of answer the
question
um that can reduce the levels of this in
the intellectual proteins so for example
vitamin d if you feed the worms vitamin
d from an early age it massively reduces
the amount of protein activities that
you see with aging and you see this
massive lifespan increase too
but it's not a simple story actually
because it seems like maybe there are
some protein areas that are actually
beneficial so it might be the case that
protein aggregates have evolved to kind
of soak up toxic monomers so there are
some people who think that might be the
case in alzheimer's disease where you
see these plaques
so there are compounds that we think
like bioflavon tea where contrary to our
private belief about like with a vitamin
d story
they actually increase the level of
protein insoluble proteins and so it
could be the case that thigh flavin tea
and other like other amyloid binding
proteins are protected because they kind
of
accelerate this for us in a beneficial
way so they bring about bring down these
monomers into protective brackets
and they you know
one thing we'd like to do is combine
pharmacological approaches with genetics
as a way to try and get a mechanism and
with five flavin tea we you know we went
into it thinking oh thigh flavor t binds
aggregating proteins therefore it might
prevent aggregation which it does in the
test tube
and therefore that might be a great
thing
um and and and it worked but then when
we started doing the genetics we
realized it wasn't just stagnate itself
it needed all the components of protein
stasis
in the worm to actually work so if you
took away chaperones if you took away
the heat shock factor if you took away
the protein zone functions or autophagy
it didn't work
and so there's this dependency on
natural uh protein aggregation
degradation processes uh for for to see
the beneficial effects
and maybe one other thing to say about
this is that
the the proteostasis i think makes a
really important connection to disease
because as
the eddy described there that you know
the the
detergent in soluble proteins they're
behaving
biochemically like
a beta
alpha nuclei you know the proteins of of
very significant terrible neurological
disease exactly the same and we believe
that that's not an accident there's a
there's a connection that is supported
so it's like on from that then obviously
alzheimer's is something that we've been
struggling to try and kill for a long
time and so therefore how translatable
do you think that discovery of these
other compounds will be to human
diseases i mean we're looking at it
we're actually moving compounds from
worms through into mammalian cells
through into mouse models
um
it's hard to say i mean i think that
many of us at least in the aging
community think that one of the major
failures in alzheimer's therapy
development
has has been ignoring the aging
component
you know and you know many ways some
some researchers have been using
mice that have an accelerated
alzheimer's pathology uh almost
eliminating the aging component at all
so then you cure that then you go into a
real you know animal or person and the
aging component is the dominant thing
that's causing the disease so i don't
know i i would love to think that this
is a
a really
um novel and possibly successful way to
develop therapeutics for alzheimer's and
the the nia have put significant
resources into i think testing this
general idea which is which is great so
we'll see
yes but yeah i mean it's pretty
promising especially and so there's
something you kind of hinted at a bit
earlier with going back to this uh like
itp testing study
where you said that you saw variants
even like within um
this one species with the same
intervention and so i mean i think i saw
something once about how this the same
thing the c elegans study um
nicolas stross
um he showed that maybe it was like this
the fastest element to aging or
something noise but like everything the
conditions are the same there's a
necessity identical to see what's
happening in this situation it is it's
bizarre actually and you know people
been doing these experiments for
25 years or something
and for the first time we saw because we
did so many of them
that you would set up an experiment
under a very tight protocol very you
know standard operating procedure
and you get a result worms lived 15 days
you set up again same strain not even
with a drug at this point same strain
and now the worms are living 22 days
on average
and we would do this again and again and
again and in the end actually what we
saw was that the
lifespan was kind of biphasic
it was it's something called stochastic
obviously something we're doing but we
don't know what it is but in in all
three of the labs involved in the citp
we would have short lifespan and long
lifespan for the same strain under
identical conditions interesting
and and so i in a way it made me feel
better because i thought well this this
maybe explains some of the problems in
the literature
um because you know one lab could be you
know in a short-lived mode another lab
could be in a long-lived mode and then
you come in with a drug and who knows
what's going to happen under those
different different physiologies or
biology or something
um
and it's the kind of thing where you
know i don't know in the past you would
see
you would see it like a short lifespan
and you think oh well something went
wrong with that experiment it must be
contamination or something else going on
there and you would you just throw it
away
and
we decided no nothing gets thrown away
everything is real everything is natural
variation on this particular phenotype
of lifespan and um
i'm at peace
[Laughter]
actually speaking just of how you do
these experiments how do you actually go
about studying c algorithms because i
mean i showed to many of my viewers that
seems like a crazy like how do you study
bonds like yeah
yeah i mean obviously that's a really
simple experiment you just described
where you can just add a compound to a
plate and then you can watch the worms
die essentially you can score them when
they die sounds gross uh yeah but we
would pop them with a wire
to see and if they move they're alive
that's about as sophisticated as they
get something yeah yeah we can't check
their ports
um yeah so i mean but they're they're
actually transparent which is amazing
because it means that you can look at
the body structures
down the microscope and so there are
many different labs that generate these
amazing strains where they express
proteins with like a gfp or rf
fluorescent protein and you can just see
it i mean because the worms are
transparent so you can watch trafficking
of proteins through the autophagy
pathway for example melania hansen's lab
and they're new to the book and they
just moved up here and they're like the
world leading experts on this so they
have these fantastic strains where you
can yeah look at the quenching of these
fluorescents that the explorer falls
through
um that's just one example
and then you know the the transparency
you know any
student can come into the lab or a high
school student coming into the lab over
the summer show them young worms and old
worms and their own eager plates or
there's a little bit of e coli on there
for food
and it's it's blindingly obvious which
of which you know the young worms are
moving around pretty fast they're eating
they're moving in the sinusoidally like
this
the older worms that get to the point
where they're not moving at all and you
look through
literally root through the skin and you
see that the tissues are completely
disorganized and there's all sorts of
weird vacuoles and dark patches and
things
like aging is happening in front of your
eyes for 20 days and that's i think
that's
something that many of us
continue to be
attracted to the war model is that when
you see a mutation
or a drug
that stops that from happening
it just
as the switch goes off in your head you
go this is incredible this this
um
idea of lifespan is is malleable it's
plastic
it can do something about it yeah it's
definitely and i think that goes
backwards saying about how we define and
how i guess the both of us um aging has
constant disease does seem kind of you
know facing all this exciting data and
so we've spoken about some of your
research but what are like the main i
guess research questions in your lab
um
i kind of leave up to these guys to be
honest like you know they think that
you know we as
lab leaders we all have our own ideas
but the real creativity comes from the
trainees the students and postdocs
and and so that that means that things
change all the time
so for example um you know a couple of
years ago one of our colleagues julie
anderson she's a phd student who was
very interested in exercising
parkinson's disease
and uh but then sort of wanted to do
some warm warm work on this and so
there's an exercise model for the worms
um so she worked with her lab
uh mina schmidt um
published a really nice paper on
exercise and then another phd student
comes to the loved ones sex wants to
work on exercise as well that was i had
nothing to do with any of that right
the general themes are really about the
relationship between
stress
as as shown by the protein stasis
example that he was talking about this
lack of protein homeostasis with age
and then and then now much to my
surprise the connection with disease
and we definitely have
shifted from genetics to more chemical
biology approach so we're very
interested in continuing to screen for
compounds that suppress
aging pathologies in the worm like you
can make a make a worm that exhibits
aspects of alzheimer's disease or
aspects of parkinson's and so and those
those worms are super easy to screen for
chemical compounds that suppress those
phenotypes so a lot of the compounds
we've been talking about until now
started back in those screens like
vitamin d
we had no intention of working with
vitamin d that wasn't an idea that was a
came out a screen of natural products
that suppressed alzheimer's pathology
and a worm and then we realized that
actually had these amazing effects on
normal aging as well in the worm and
surprisingly that was super interesting
to clinicians because
they don't really have a good
explanation as to why deficiency vitamin
d deficiency in adults
leads to elevation in risk of disease
cancers
diabetes neurological disease and we
looked at mine
that said that's aging that's
accelerated
so the human deficiency could be you
know in some way related again a
hypothesis not a conclusion but um
but yeah so so i i think that the themes
move around all the time
and that's great because every new
person that comes into the lab brings
new ideas um but the overall theme is
can we explain this of aging disease
connection
so firstly how do you actually exercise
the one but secondly i mean just what
are the limitations as well with working
with this modern organism
well do you think the limitations um
maybe i can answer the exercise
first yeah so really simply the worms
will naturally swim when you put them in
water or put them in a you know buffer
solution so you can simply
pick up the worms and drop them in
solution and they'll swim happily for a
few hours so
yeah yeah they do these characteristic
body bends yeah
and then they become exhausted so you
know they'll do it for a certain amount
of time and then you can tell that you
know that's that's their limit yeah and
it makes them hungry actually so if once
you put them back because obviously
they're they're not in their food at
times but when you put them back to
their food then they'll gobble it all up
much faster than usually
yeah yeah kind of like humans
sorry what was the second part looks
like limitations or buy from a farms
yeah i mean you mean
well when you submit a grant everyone
tells you about the limitations and it's
alarm worm right
it's it's not it's not a mouse and
there's a lot of biology that must be
specific to the worm
but going back to the amazing success
rate of moving from worms to mice with
chemical compounds i think says that
it's it's it's despite the limitations
it's a good model to find things that
would be important for human aging so
one example is our colleague simon
mellow published a paper we were
collaborators with um last year
where he tested the compound that we'd
identified in the worm is extending
lifespan
and he was looking at it in the mouse
and he was doing a whole panel of
different things like cardiovascular
health metabolism
bone health
and he showed that um
this compound was reducing
the rate of bone loss by about 30
percent it's a very significant change
in bone loss
and then our colleague julie anderson
has preliminary data showing that this
self-same compound is protected against
parkinson's disease
by protecting the dopaminergic neurons
and preventing alpha-synucleigation
so
so you've got this compound that you
find in a worm
that doesn't have bone
it barely has a brain
and then you move it into a mouse and it
protects against both both domains of
aging
and i i think that's amazing i don't
know if it's going to be this is going
to be common i mean obviously
rapamycin's another great example of
this yeah um but it but it does say that
maybe the gyroscience idea has got
something going for it and that when you
know you're you're going down a drug
development for alzheimer's you're
possibly also going down the drug
development route for other crowd
diseases at the same time oh yeah sure
is called hvx and actually it's uh
structurally related to this
we chose hbx because it's a bit more
drug-like
um and
we know we we actually did not see a
lifespan extension in the mouse um but
most of the math studies you're looking
at one concentration
you know you're making the best guess
they're very expensive you can't do a
whole you know it's this entire study
had 700 mice in it um but with four
interventions um so it was it was a
large large study but even then you know
you can it's hard to go back and say
well let's try another 10 concentrations
and see if we'll get the less traffic
but but the effect on bone was amazing
and so um i guess we'll be speaking now
about the limitations of the one but
what's the future potential of the women
spammers of like i guess how is new
technology being incorporated so we have
like crystal new high throughput
methods of screening like um i guess
imaging techniques but how is that being
applied to yes studying ones
i mean i mean all of it's been applied i
mean you know crispr is obviously making
it easier to make strains and to go into
these wild strains that are recently
isolated so you're not dealing with sort
of lab adaptive strains
um
[Music]
you know single cell is is now possible
in the worm and that's something yeah
yeah
uh it's just i mean
i mean every you know any technique you
hear about someone's going to try it in
a worm yeah and and you know just i
think
it
you always want to use the best possible
system to ask the question you're asking
for sure
and and many times that's not the word
and we've got people in love who are
working in cell culture and obviously
the much love that they've done
um
for me personally i think it's it's
the aging component that eddie talked
about earlier the fact that swarming so
rapidly there's results within 20 days
for the most part and i keep going back
to that thinking well if we're
interested in combinations of compounds
if we're interested in compounds that
have much larger effects than we've seen
exploring new chemical space we really
don't explore much chemical space
really we you know it's
there's there's only been tens of
thousands of compounds looked at for
aging
in muslim worms
and there are millions and millions of
compounds as you know and there's
different chemistries that create really
interesting compounds that are very
different from the drug-like libraries
and when i look at that i think yeah
probably just didn't
warm how much space they take off in
terms of like storage space oh well you
know they're
they're one millimeter in length yeah we
grow them on eager plates that are gay
size
and we keep them in plastic box and in
incubators at 20 degrees c which is
optimal for reproduction
and uh so
yeah i mean
i mean compared to the mouse my goodness
this is an incredibly economical model
right
although it's still labor intensive a
lot of things are still done manually
despite you know some automation that we
use
and they're hermaphrodites
so what does that mean for sex defendant
differences or
interested in at the moment yeah yeah
that's a really good question i mean we
do you can generate males and so it's
possible to do males versus
um and that's something that actually
the lab has just been talking about it's
in a lot of me this week
we're thinking about maybe screening
some compounds in males
and to get around some limitations of
working with them for lives um
but yeah i'm not sure how much of a
mapredie is
is a female i don't know if we can make
that distinction yeah i mean there's
certainly lots of mutants where they're
truly female or right you know generate
males all the time that kind of thing so
there are variations that think about
um
there isn't enough done on this it's a
really really good question and actually
i think the worm is a very interesting
model to think about these things and
you know other people like jennifer
garrison here at the buckard certainly
think about this this kind of this kind
of approach
um and historically uh as you as you
know it's been a disaster and most most
research has been done in males aloft
here and thankfully the nih has kind of
fixed that and it's impossible now to to
have a grant on meals only
that's so that's that's a great thing so
yeah i mean i guess it will be
interesting to see if there are
differences when you can have
america yeah
and so i guess talking more generally
about the fields um where it is at the
moment and it's future potential are
there any like other areas of like i
guess longevity research that you're
interested in like there's been a lot of
interest around uh cellular
reprogramming at the moment so i've been
trying to know what i don't know i mean
uh i could yeah just for your general
interest besides protestants and farms
yeah that's a lot
yeah yeah so this is something that
we've talked about quite a lot in the
lab about um can we do reprogramming
worms and is is the case that they do
have orthologs of the yamanaka factors
and so it is in theory it should be
quite simple experiment to do and i know
that there is
i'm pretty sure there's a lab in
switzerland that's trying to do that
right now
so we haven't tried that so i can't say
anything about the data right now
yeah yeah i mean you know
this this institute has something like
160 scientists working on aging or
age-related disease
and and so it kind of represents quite a
lot of diverse approaches um you know
metabolism epigenetics you know
you can imagine everyone's we have a
huge interest in sellers and essence
here
which you know has been amazing to watch
because
20 years ago it was not even um
obvious that celsius has actually
contributed to aging and even the you
know the best people in the field judy
can visit in one year
you know would say i don't know i don't
know if this is really contributing to
aging but my goodness well it's amazing
how it's it's developed and how it's
grown and um
i think everyone's interested in that
even if we're just spectators right yeah
yeah i would say i'm biased because
that's what i studied but yeah they're
definitely very interesting and so i
think we'll just like generally now like
do you have any advice of people being
uh like scientific advice like how the
diligence in performing experiments or
just like more general advice if you're
curious and finding out more information
about science
oh
that's good um
i mean i i think that that
it's really important to
read broadly if you can
i don't right now but but the people in
my lab do and you can just see all these
ideas percolating up to the surface and
collaborations i think
collaboration is possibly the most
important thing we've got at the moment
um you know between labs and a single
institute between universities between
institutes across the world um you know
and so eddie's collaborating with max
plank right now and
um that i think that's super important
and it's hard
it's hard to to make these things work
um but but stick at it you know talk to
people when we get back to going to
meetings go to meetings you know
and make connections with people and
you know come up with experiments that
work for
both of you are all three of you are all
for i think that should
yeah yeah i'd like to say more about
that i think that
i think that everybody maybe at some
point in their lives have this feeling
of imposter syndrome
yeah it's still happening
and uh yeah i think people should just
um
realize that you know everybody's been
there and that you know everybody's
trying to learn and reaching out to
somebody and saying you think their
research is cool can we have a chat
about it it's actually seen as a
positive thing somebody reach out to me
to have a chat about my research if
anything i'm not flat so don't be afraid
to reach out to people you've never met
before
um
at any level
scientists love talking about science
right i mean they're not talking about
their own science especially so so
once you make that move
i don't think anyone ever says no i
don't want to talk about it you know i
mean they want to talk yeah yeah i've
definitely been realizing more and more
that there are it's going down an
academic path isn't um doesn't mean you
have to stay in academia forever and so
you know the biotech space right now is
exploding and aging and um like i mean
in the bay area it's just it's just
crazy how many people are interested and
i don't think that it's a once you leave
academia you can never come back either
i think that the doors open in both
directions right absolutely i would
encourage people to just think broadly
about it and you know
keep their options open
sure and so why do you see like the
field in like i mean 10 years time i
know that's a hard question but yeah do
you have any thoughts
it's always 10 years isn't it
i i
i mean i'm very optimistic for the field
i i think
we will see breakthroughs in humans in
the sense of
suppressing human aging pathologies and
maybe disease
but but the field has to deliver that
and you know all the all the biotech
interests right now is phenomenal i love
it i'd love to see this because it's
money coming into a field that was
essentially
it was a science project right that's
what it was basic scientists doing basic
stuff following their curiosity and
loving doing what they're doing and
publishing their paper snaps it
but then there's this rising hope that
well this this is actually for people
for people
and and so to see an industry emerge is
really really exciting and i i dearly
hope that we'll be get some wins from
this in humans in the short term and
then i think it will explode
and
not to be too dramatic
maybe within 10 years biomedicine will
be transformed by this field
um
that's why i hope i'm optimistic
obviously i'm in the same position as
you i feel so sick about it you're
hoping to have a job in 10
years yeah i mean obviously the results
of the team trial should be out in five
six years and so maybe metformin will be
the first
aging drug
um i wouldn't be surprised if we see
winds with rapamycin in human trials um
yeah i feel like like you said it's
the floodgates may open at that point
because if people realize that we can
attack all these different age-related
diseases in one go then everyone's mind
will be open to that science idea
and as you guys are going to do it like
it's your generation and
very fascinating very effective you're
here you know
communicating to people about this field
is super exciting thank you for for
doing that and and i think that that
you know the more we can
inform people that there's something
potentially
special could happen that could
transform maybe even their own lives in
their late life um
it's truly amazing i mean you know
one of the problems i think the field
has had is
is the challenge of talking about aging
especially for people who are a little
bit older um
you know
you can't just take a camera through a
geriatric psychiatric board and see the
misery there and come out the other end
and say do something about this people i
mean people don't react to that very
well it's it's too hard it's so hard and
it's also
it's almost impossible to imagine we can
do something about that
but what's happening in the animals says
we can
so
that's where the optimism comes from i
guess yeah i'm sure i mean i'm the same
as you brave i'm mostly up to myself and
yeah i hope that i guess still can also
contribute to the field so i just want
to say thank you to book of you for like
talking about your research it's been a
really interesting and like fun
conversation so i'm sure we'll hear more
about the worms
absolutely they're not going away
so yeah thank you again i know yes it's
been pretty fun thank you very much so i
hope you've learned something in this
video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
so hi gordon hi
sorry
you can just call me edward it's fine